au canada peut-on annoncer et vendre des
produits en dollars américains on a
parfois l'impression que certaines
compagnies américaines manque d'égard
envers leur petit voisin du nord elle ne
se donne même pas la peine d'afficher le
prix de ce qu'elles vendent ici dans
notre monnaie nationale
ce n'est peut-être pas un crime de lèse
majesté mais parfois on dirait que ces
entreprises veulent donner l'illusion
que leurs produits sont moins chers par
exemple dans cette infopub le prix et en
dollars américains c'est indiqué là mais
le narrateur lui de l'ancien jamais pour
19 dollars 99 pour seulement 29 dollars
99 bon les entreprises ont le droit
d'annoncer le prix de leurs produits en
dinars algériens si elles le veulent
mais les lois exigent que cela ne nous
induisent pas en erreur aux dernières
nouvelles aucune entreprise n'a été
condamné pour cause de tromperie avec
des dollars américains mais bien des
gens trouvent qu'elles se tiennent
parfois juste sur la ligne et ça c'est
énervant à défaut de mieux adapter cette
devise je ne tiens pas pour acquis que
les prix sont en dollars canadiens
anselmo
[Musique]